is it possible that we are currently
living inside a video game that the
future you designed can you give hints
as to how one would Escape if this was a
video game
how can a video game character escape to
outside the video game
are these things you don't consider when
you design the game actually we do
because in the kind of games that we
make
we want it to be as open as possible so
you know when you start a game you're
always testing it what can I do what
would the game allow me to do and you
check everything you try to pick up the
you know the mugs you try every door you
collide with everything like hey what
are the rules of this world we try to do
games where
you know we say yes as much as possible
that leads to some level of Chaos
but if you were stuck in a video game
you would you would try everything and
usually you're going to find a door or a
space where the designers didn't uh
anticipate you piling all those crates
up and getting over a wall
that they didn't expect right so it's
not a designed doorway out it's uh
accidental unintended or way out and
it's a it's a happy bug you could like
trim and show just get in the ocean and
go to like just keep going keep going
right but the more realistic the game
becomes the harder it is to find that
door the the bigger the world the bigger
the open world
and then as we do it we learn
they're gonna find a way so just don't
try to pen them in usually we leave like
this developer test cell yeah area in
the game that we don't anticipate anyone
will find and and they ultimately find
it it usually has crates of all the
weapons in the game and things like that
the little hints you drop now will just
drive people mad which is something I
enjoy deeply